landesweite demos der kulturbranche
kunst kultur und veranstaltungen sind
die großen verlierer in corona zeiten
allein 5000 menschen demonstrieren
gestern in berlin darunter herbert
grönemeyer einzelne hand und kraft der
veranstaltungsbranche das gleiche recht
auf prompte grundsicherung wir alle
industrien betriebe und unternehmen bei
denen das jetzt direkt und unkompliziert
gegangen ist wir sind vielleicht nicht
die maschine und der motor deutschland
aber wir alle zusammen sind die
rauschende seele
wir sind der öffentliche herzschlag die
isolation fakt ist theater stehen leer
konzerte und festivals sind abgesagt
netflix und co ersetzen das kino für
hunderttausende beschäftigte eine
katastrophe
die soforthilfe längst aufgebraucht neue
arbeit nicht in sicht muss der staat
helfen ist unsere kultur in gefahr dass
systemrelevant ist es in der pharma-
muss dazu aber jetzt auch sagen langsam
aber sicher lockert sich hier und da
wieder was es wird wieder mehr gedreht
es wird wieder mehr produziert kleinere
konzerte werden auch zugelassen
nichtsdestotrotz christine wir ging sie
in den letzten monaten also mal so mal
so
ich hatte einfach wahnsinnig viel freie
zeit war ja beruflich sehr sehr viel
verschoben wurde bzw gecancelt
ausgefallen wurde
und dann steht mir natürlich finanziell
auch von der unsicherheit auch überhaupt
in dieser planungssicherheit es ist als
freiberuflicher schauspieler sowieso
immer schwierig so zu langfristig zu
planen und was was kommt im nächsten
jahr wovon werde ich leben haben ein
extra fenster auch teilweise ist kam na
ja ich bin für mich persönlich bin ich
ein sehr optimistisch gestimmte mensch
dass ich immer sage irgendwie geht's für
mich weiter und zur not mache ich was
anderes aber es ist natürlich nicht
jeder so eingestellt
und natürlich gab es auch mal immer so
moment wo ich dachte so misst wie sie es
jetzt auf dem konto aus
die wie wird es weitergehen und ja nicht
nur für mich persönlich sondern wirklich
für die gesamte branche also mit vielen
vielen kollegen mit denen ich geredet
habe die musiker zum beispiel ist auch
so ein fachgebiet wo es einfach ganz
ganz schwierig war jetzt mit den
orchestern wieder weiter zu machen und
es ist einfach so entsteht dann
plötzlich vor 0 das haben sich die
hilfsgelder beantragt haben sie das ich
habe auch ich habe diese sofort hilfe
beantragt das hat ein bisschen länger
gedauert weil der antrag für mich
kompliziert aber als ich dachte
aber ich habe dann tatsächlich auch was
bewilligt bekommen aber das hilft
natürlich
es ist eine überbrückung gewesen für
einen gewissen zeitrahmen und jetzt ist
einfach so der punkt wie wird es jetzt
weitergehen es in sachen immer noch also
es gibt immer noch was was ausgefallen
ist wo ich schon mit gerechnet hatte
es ist alles noch sehr ungewiss und da
würde ich mir jetzt zum beispiel eben
wirklich vom staat wünschen dass man da
auch guckt wie kann man helfen zum
beispiel im punkt auf steuern also ich
habe im letzten jahr zum beispiel sehr
sehr viel selbstständig da muss ich
viele steuern zahlen die muss ich jetzt
eigentlich ein teil eben zurückzahlen
und ich habe das geld momentan nicht
also so weil ich brauchte es einfach
jetzt gerade so zum leben und unter
einem möglichen das wird zum beispiel so
ein ansatz wo ich mir wünschen würde der
staat würde uns künstlern da in so einer
situation unter die arme greifen und
diese steuererleichterung wir können
nicht in kurzarbeit oder sonstige was
aber das neue steuer home office geht
auch nicht online auftritte kann man
natürlich machen gibt nicht so viel geld
oder gar keins wie auch immer und es ist
nicht das gleiche wenn man mutig die
harte zeit
in deiner laufbahn als schauspielerin
das jetzt sagt also jetzt ist es
wirklich noch ein haar die es seit jetzt
man sich nie gewünscht hat eigentlich ja
weil es um einfach den großen begriff
einfach kunst und was macht die kunst
und die kultur mit uns darum geht es
also es geht jetzt auch nicht nur auch
für für sehr sehr viele existenz bedroht
und so um geld aber es geht auch so
etwas ist wenn wir jetzt nicht mehr ins
theater gehen können was ist denn wenn
jetzt die ganzen film premieren abgesagt
werden von den film die schon produziert
sind aber wenn überhaupt keine filme
mehr produziert werden dürfen weil es
unter sicherheitsmaßnahmen abständen
einhalten keine kuss sehen keine liebe
sehen was weiß ich gar nicht mehr
möglich ist und wir zum beispiel nicht
mehr diese zerstreuung in der kultur
finden können auch als zuschauer also da
rede ich ja auch als zuschauerin
wo soll das hinführen wo geht denn dann
unser unserer umwelt kultur wo wir also
was wir erleben dass wir fürs leben
braucht wo soll das hinführen und das
empfinde ich gerade als mit den
stärksten einbruch in meiner
persönlichen sich natürlich auf keinen
fall noch einen zweiten lockdown gehe
ich davon aus dass beantwortet sich dann
wahrscheinlich auch von alleine dass das
dann noch spezifischer sich zuspitzen
würde ja das ist natürlich so dass viele
menschen denkt na ja kommen die
schauspielerinnen die spielt im tatort
mit die verdient doch millionen
irgendwie was zur seite gelegt haben
ja wir haben ja eine gute einschaltquote
im tatort meines wegen der zwölf
millionen zuschauer sage ich mal sowie
hauswirtschaft und dann sag ich mit jan
josef immer wenn jeder uns einen euro
geben würde das versuche ich steckte er
die immer ein und sagt mir dabei ja
nicht so du hast nämlich mal einem
interview gesagt dass wenn du auch nur
zehn prozent vom gerät von ihm bekam es
ja eigentlich hätte wir uns mit den
verhandlungen
die sind natürlich unter den tisch
gefallen die behandlung die verhandlung
aber nie aber was ziemlich geklärt denn
eigentlich für ein tatort über 100000
tat glaube ja ich will jetzt vielleicht
schreibt er mir gleich christine du bist
ein idiot aber es also der krieg schon
so viel krieg nicht zurück dass du nicht
so viel kristall sowas ja das ist
natürlich noch mal so eine mann-frau
geschichte auch in unserer branche dass
die gehälter
längst nicht angeglichen sind er ist ja
es geht um erfolg und gute verhandlungen
um das man das in den verhandlungen sich
auch so erlauben kann er so wahnsinnig
erfolgreich sind
ich weiß nicht da müsste ich auf die
barrikaden gehen aus spannendes gelesen
genau zu dem thema und das fand ich
irgendwie macht das total sinn dass
viele frauen nicht alle natürlich aber
viele frauen die verhandeln die
verhandeln nach ihrem selbstbewusstsein
naja oder sie am ende hat genau
selbstwertgefühl und männer die
verhandeln nach leistungen oder den
wunschträumen ohne aber ich finde man
kann auch mit nichts besser erfasst
werden als mit seiner leidenschaft das
würden wir man auch umsonst machen unter
umständen auch wenn das nicht gut ist
das konto legen aber wir lieben das was
wir tun und wenn das das gegenüber spürt
dann ist das ein ganz schlechter
verhandlungsspielraum bestimmt als er
denn nachverhandelt und auch noch ist es
eigentlich so dass man sich irgendwann
nebenjob suchte ich meine schauspielerei
ist ja immer so eine sache wo man
irgendwie nie weiß gut jetzt tatort ist
natürlich so eine regelmäßige
einkommensquelle aber ist an so einem
punkt wo man sagt aber ich glaube ich
mache jetzt im allgäu ein café auf oder
ich suche mir irgendwie nicht irgendwas
auch nur ist sie also das habe ich
bisher noch nicht gemacht aber
unabhängig jetzt von der korona krise
habe ich mit so was tatsächlich immer
schon geliebäugelt irgendwie nur was
anderes und mit einer kleinen
frühstückspension im allgäu so das macht
frühstück selber aber ich mache
frühstück selber dass meine zweite
leidenschaft frühstück zubereiten
also natürlich gibt es sowas auch solche
überlegungen aber sonst bin ich ja auch
zb als schauspielerin so breit
aufgestellt dass ich auch lesung mache
moderation in preisverleihung oder
irgendwie sowas
also da gibt es ja genügend
unterschiedlichkeit auch an job so also
was ich jetzt nicht als nebenberuf oder
so bezeichnen möchte sondern einfach was
auch so dazu gehören ihr flug wieder
dass diese strukturelle benachteiligung
jetzt auch während der kubakrise dass
man das noch intensiver empfindet ist
man so ein bisschen wütend da will man
mehr ehrlichkeit wenn man es gerechter
haben oder ich glaube diese zeit
rentieren in diesen fragen
also ich glaube was also ja was heißt
gerechter also ich meine du von also
weniger
ich verdiene natürlich weniger und ich
finde der austausch ist einfach
schwierig auch wenn wir irgendwie online
mäßig so vernetzt sind aber wenn man ist
gerade so ein bisschen in der
schockstarre immer noch irgendwie und
fragt sich sowie wie kommt man daraus
wie können wir uns zusammentun
wie können wir uns mobilisieren und
impulse geben und diese dieses diese art
von gemeinschaftsgefühl so die die
entsteht es entsteht irgendwie gerade
nicht so wirklich und das finden wir
darüber reden ich kann zum beispiel
nicht verstehen darum dass wir die ganze
zeit darüber reden wann wir wieder
fußball schauen können dass wir aber
nicht darüber reden man will wieder in
die theater gehen aber ich glaube ganz
hinter dürfen wir in dieser krise unser
herz verlieren
ich verstehe dass es auf der
prioritätenliste der menschen gerade
weit unten steht weil viele um die
existenz fürchten weil viele sich fragen
wie es weitergeht kann aber nur sagen
wenn wir wenn wir dieser branche nicht
helfen und da geht es nicht nur um
existenzen sondern da geht es ja auch um
unsere wohl um unsere herzens gesundheit
dann geht alles den bach und ja wir
gehen mit den fußballstadien machen
sondern auf das große geld das thema im
endeffekt das ist ja leider die lauten
studenten noch um geld auch millionen
[Musik]